being an entrepreneur is obviously an
intimidating
and daunting job what has been your
biggest challenge so far
my biggest challenge has been getting
the word out
i don't have really any advertising so
it's just been word of mouth
and i started with a facebook page
that's all
but i want to be able to get that word
out get those new customers in
and keep them in just like i've got all
my loyal customers
but also utilizing my time wisely
making sure that i can get those
cheesecakes out
making sure that the the process
is streamlined one right after another
i'm making a list um okay um
first of all i think you should start a
facebook group uh
that is based in the love of cheesecakes
i don't care if there's one person that
joins
or a hundred and anything in between
there are probably other like-minded
cheesecake lovers out there
not only is it just fun to talk to
somebody
about the thing you love most but it
continues that word of mouth
sure number two i noticed you did not
have an instagram no
do you see my face so
i went and just secured you an instagram
account called oh for the love of
cheesecake
good thank you so it's all yours
and we will have to switch an email
afterwards but i just didn't want
anybody to grab it in the next few
seconds
because this is going to be a game
changer for you
welcome to the whatever century this is
21st um and what i want you to do
is i want you to do an instagram rabbit
hole dive i would like you to not only
find sites
that speak to you visually but i would
like
you to find sites that do not speak to
you because
knowing what you don't want is as vital
as knowing what you do want so i want
you to get really clear on that
okay next a logo
i mocked up some inspiration logos
and i did i went two different
directions because i kind of wanted you
to eyeball it and tell me if like one
was a visceral yes or no
will you take a look at these yes
absolutely
okay so here's sort of a modern timeless
more
circular very focused on the cheesecake
slice itself and then i would like you
to look at this other logo
that really hits the word more
did either one of those speak to you or
more importantly
not speak to you the one that has the
negative space
did not speak to me but the one that had
the o
in the pie i like that one
i actually saw your pupils dilate when
you saw that and
when i saw this i was like oh
i'm really understanding the title of
your company
better than i ever have and graphic
treatment can really help
tell not only the story story but the
cadence of the title
this was something i'm sorry you
overheard or you had a friend say
what was the story behind your title i
had a friend say it
she took a bite of cheesecake and she
went oh
for the love of cheesecake and that was
it that
it just stuck so yeah the o
is vital
this is your cheesecake by the way okay
[Music]
oh my gosh yeah definitely quit your day
job
it's incredible it is incredible
i've never had a piece of cheesecake and
i think that was your triple chocolate
layer
that has that much of a prevalence of
chocolate and yet does not
lose the essence and the creaminess and
the texture of cheesecake well done oh
my gosh
oh for the love of cheesecake i think
what they did with the o
is very heavenly too i'm so glad that
you like it
that means everything actually because
you believing in it
is going to make you want to go to the
mountaintop and talk about it on your
new instagram account
and your new facebook group yay
and also um we uh
have another little surprise for you um
which is we want to give you five
thousand dollars
to use at your disposal
what you see fit i would reserve some of
the money
to hire some help
because you cannot do this alone and if
there's one
reason that anything i have ever done
has worked in any way shape or form it's
because
i chose to work with amazing people and
i
never did anything alone oh i certainly
will take that advice
well i love that you are going out there
and showing people
that we have one life this is not a
dress rehearsal
and we only totally true have so much
time
to i don't know if it's get it right or
just
simply be happy which is anything but
simple i
applaud you so much thanks
okay finally thank you stephanie i have
been dying to get back into this
good luck we'll be in touch i'd love to
talk about this
and keep in touch with each other okay
all right thank you so much
[Music]